This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. After World War I in Frankfurt, Germany, the city government was taking on a big project. A lot of residents were in dire straits, and in the second half of the 1920s, the city built over 10,000 public housing units. It was some of the earliest modern architecture, simple, clean, and uniform. The massive housing effort was, in many ways, I poppingly impressive with all new construction
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。第一次世界大战后，在德国法兰克福，市政府正在进行一项大工程。当时许多居民生活困苦，于是在20世纪20年代下半叶，该市建造了超过10,000套公共住房。这是最早的现代建筑之一，简单、整洁且统一。这项大规模的住房建设在许多方面都令人惊叹，采用了全新的建筑结构
and sleek cutting edge architecture. But one room in these new housing units was far and away the most lauded and influential. And that was the kitchen. That's reporter and friend of the show, Katie Thornton. Many consider this room, which has come to be known as the Frankfurt kitchen, to be nothing less than the first modern kitchen. And looking at it today is a real trip, because you'd be forgiven for thinking that you're
以及时尚前卫的建筑风格。但在这些新住房中，有一个房间最受赞誉，影响也最深远。那就是厨房。这是本节目的记者兼朋友凯蒂·桑顿。许多人认为这个后来被称为“法兰克福厨房”的房间，正是现代厨房的鼻祖。今天再看它，会有一种奇妙的感觉，因为如果你以为自己
looking at an IKEA display. It's tidy, practical, and simple. Okay, shall we? Shall we? Shall. A handful of these original Frankfurt kitchen still exist, mostly in museums, and Katie practical and simple. OK, shall we? Shall we? A handful of these original Frankfurt kitchens still exist, mostly in museums, and Katie went to check out one at Mia, the Minneapolis Institute of Art.
是在看宜家样板间，那也情有可原。它整洁、实用且简单。好了，我们开始吧？开始吧？开始。这些最初的法兰克福厨房中，只有少数幸存下来，大多保存在博物馆里，而凯蒂实用且简单。好了，我们开始吧？开始吧？少数这些最初的法兰克福厨房依然存在，大多在博物馆里，凯蒂去明尼阿波利斯艺术学院（Mia）参观了其中一个。
OK, watch your step. Thanks. Jennifer Komar Olivarez, head of exhibition planning and strategy at the museum, led me over the stanchion and into this room to see it firsthand. And it's honestly kind of strange to see it in a museum because to our modern eyes, it doesn't appear to be high art. So coming in is the electric cooker. It just looks like a kitchen. It has two burners on the top,
好的，小心台阶。谢谢。博物馆展览策划与战略主管詹妮弗·科马尔·奥利瓦雷斯带我越过护栏，走进这个房间，亲眼看看它。老实说，在博物馆里看到它感觉有点奇怪，因为以我们现代人的眼光来看，它似乎算不上什么高雅艺术。走进来就是电灶。它看起来就像个普通的厨房。顶部有两个炉头，
one large, one and one small one, so assuming you're like... It may look ordinary, but many of the things that are now standard kitchen features were pretty unheard of before the Frankfurt kitchen. Things like a modern stove. So wow, I'm sure it was transformative and well planned storage to stash your plates and glasses. These I think are for pot storage and a way to wash dishes
一个大的，一个小的，所以假设你……它看起来可能很普通，但在法兰克福厨房出现之前，许多现在标准的厨房功能在当时闻所未闻。比如现代炉灶。哇，我相信它具有变革性，还有规划良好的储物空间来存放盘子和玻璃杯。我想这些是用来放锅的，还有一种洗碗方式
that didn't involve hauling a heavy tub of water into the house. It's a double sink. And racks for drying those dishes. The idea is to have them dry off the counter to free up the counter space for other things. Even the countertops themselves were revolutionary. Because before this, there weren't long, continuous surfaces that were uniform and height. Most kitchens just had whatever random assortment of tables you could throw in them. And my back aches just thinking about
不需要把沉重的水桶搬进屋里。这是一个双水槽。还有晾干碗碟的架子。其理念是让它们在台面上晾干，从而腾出台面空间做其他事情。甚至台面本身也是革命性的。因为在此之前，没有高度统一的长条连续表面。大多数厨房只是随意摆放着各种桌子。一想到要
hunching over their variable heights while prepping food. The Frankfurt kitchen now appears so commonplace that it's difficult to comprehend just how groundbreaking it was when it was first designed. And that's all thanks to a woman named Margareta Shutah-alohatsky. Born in 1897 in Austria, Shutalohatsky was one of the country's first woman architects. And early in her career, she started designing for people who had never been designed for on a large scale, especially women who were often saddled with child care, laundry, and cooking. She brought that same approach to the Frankfurt kitchen.
弯腰在不同高度的台面上准备食物，我的背就疼。法兰克福厨房现在看起来如此普遍，以至于很难理解它在最初设计时是多么具有开创性。这一切都要归功于一位名叫玛格丽特·舒特-利霍茨基的女性。她于1897年出生在奥地利，是该国最早的女建筑师之一。在职业生涯早期，她开始为那些从未被大规模设计考虑过的人群进行设计，尤其是那些经常被育儿、洗衣和做饭所困的女性。她将同样的方法带到了法兰克福厨房的设计中。
She wanted it to be a streamlined space that made cooking less burdensome and faster, so women could get it done and then pursue lives and jobs outside of the home. It was a feminist kitchen made with the needs of women in mind. But Chutula Hatsuki wasn't actually the first to tackle the problem of the home kitchen, a space fraught with complications for a lot of women.
她希望它成为一个精简的空间，让烹饪变得不那么繁重、更加快捷，这样女性就能完成家务，然后去追求家庭之外的生活和工作。这是一个考虑到女性需求的女性主义厨房。但舒特-利霍茨基实际上并不是第一个解决家庭厨房问题的人，这个空间对许多女性来说充满了复杂性。
In fact, by the time Chutla Hatsky designed the Frankfurt kitchen, many feminists had already been questioning whether private kitchens could ever be designed to liberate women. Or whether the kitchen itself was irredeemable, and just needed to be abolished. For much of modern history, in most cultures, kitchens were the realm of women and of servants who worked in the home. And those faces weren't considered worthy of an architect's expertise. For the most part, it's very difficult in publications of architecture
事实上，在舒特-利霍茨基设计法兰克福厨房时，许多女性主义者就已经在质疑，私人厨房是否真的能被设计成解放女性的工具。或者厨房本身是否无可救药，只需要被废除。在现代历史的大部分时间里，在大多数文化中，厨房都是女性和家中仆人的领域。而这些空间并不被认为值得建筑师投入专业知识。在很大程度上，在建筑出版物中很难
to ever find plans, photographs of kitchens. You'd see beautiful images of living rooms, even sometimes bedrooms, and just very few kitchens. This is Mary McLeod. She teaches at Columbia University's graduate school of architecture and planning. And she says what we do know about kitchens prior to the 20th century, at least in Europe and America, is that they were really unpleasant. They're hot Podges. They're full of objects with no order.
找到厨房的平面图或照片。你会看到客厅甚至卧室的精美图片，却很少看到厨房。这是玛丽·麦克劳德。她在哥伦比亚大学建筑与规划研究生院任教。她说，我们所知的20世纪之前的厨房，至少在欧洲和美国，确实非常糟糕。它们是杂乱无章的。里面堆满了杂物，毫无秩序。
It was smoky. They were really unconscionable conditions with very little air circulation or light. One American feminist from the 19th century wrote of roasted ladies. actionable conditions with very little air circulation or light. One American feminist from the 19th century wrote of roasted ladies, scorched in sooty from preparing meals day in and day out. Remember, this was before restaurants were common or affordable in the U.S. and much of Europe. No fast, easy, cheap, prepared food. So on top of raising children, plus hand washing and drying laundry, and
烟雾缭绕。那里的条件简直令人无法接受，几乎没有空气流通或光线。一位19世纪的美国女性主义者写道，女士们被烤得焦黑，满身煤烟，因为她们日复一日地准备饭菜。记住，这还是在餐馆在美国和欧洲大部分地区普及或负担得起之前。没有快捷、方便、廉价的预制食品。所以除了抚养孩子，加上手洗和晾晒衣物，以及
sometimes juggling factory jobs outside the home, preparing the 1,095 meals a year for the family was regarded as absolute drudgery by many women. Absolute drudgery that was also unpaid, and in the years after the Civil War, a number of American feminists started to argue that uncompensated housework was keeping women financially and intellectually oppressed. And one of the ways they thought they could change that was through urban design. In the period right after the Civil War,
有时还要兼顾家外的工厂工作，每年为家庭准备1,095顿饭被许多女性视为绝对的苦差事。这种绝对的苦差事还是无偿的，在内战后的几年里，一些美国女性主义者开始争论，无偿的家务劳动使女性在经济和智力上受到压迫。她们认为改变这一现状的方法之一就是通过城市设计。在内战后的那段时期，
they were debating whether or not there were new ways to organize housing that would eliminate women's unpaid labor. The Laura's Hayden is a trailblazing architectural historian and professor, Amarita Adiel. She says that some feminists thought you could design your way out of unpaid housework by removing so-called housework from houses.
她们在争论是否有新的住房组织方式可以消除女性的无偿劳动。劳拉·海登是一位开拓性的建筑历史学家和名誉教授，阿迪尔。她说，一些女性主义者认为，可以通过将所谓的家务从房屋中移除，从而设计出摆脱无偿家务劳动的途径。
And in the US, one of the early activists who called for this kind of design solution was a writer and organizer named Melisina Faye Purse. And Melisina Purse was particularly clear that women should not be expected to render unpaid services to the men and children in their households, but that they should receive some economic compensation for their laborers.
在美国，早期呼吁这种设计解决方案的活动家之一是一位名叫梅丽西娜·费伊·珀斯的作家和组织者。梅丽西娜·珀斯特别明确地指出，不应期望女性为家中的男性和孩子提供无偿服务，她们应该为自己的劳动获得一定的经济补偿。
And what she proposed was the former producers co-op of housewives in 1868, in Cambridge, Massachusetts. First started the Cambridge Cooperative Housekeeping Society, and it operated out of a big building near Harvard Square. The co-op employed women who were paid to do laundry and bake bread for nearby families. Tasks, most women had to do on their own and without pay. Producers cooperatives, where workers would pull much of their labor and their power, were common.
她提出的是1868年在马萨诸塞州剑桥市成立的家庭主妇生产者合作社。珀斯首先创办了剑桥合作家政协会，它在哈佛广场附近的一栋大楼里运作。合作社雇佣女性，支付她们报酬，为附近的家庭洗衣服和烤面包。这些任务，大多数女性不得不独自完成且没有报酬。生产者合作社，即工人们汇集大部分劳动力和力量的组织，在当时很常见。
But Persis was the first to take on housework. So she infuriated people. We thought that women shouldn't be asking for pay for the work they should be doing out of love and obligation. Persis co-op lasted for about two years, which is a feat, but she never achieved her bigger vision, which was to integrate housework cooperatives into the designs of new housing projects. She imagined big apartment blocks with collective kitchens and laundry. But other feminists were also getting interested in this idea that so-called housework should
但珀斯是第一个将家务劳动纳入其中的人。所以她激怒了人们。我们认为女性不应该为她们出于爱和义务应该做的工作索要报酬。珀斯的合作社维持了大约两年，这已经是一个壮举，但她从未实现她更大的愿景，即将家务合作社整合到新住房项目的设计中。她设想了带有集体厨房和洗衣房的大型公寓楼。但其他女性主义者也开始对这种所谓的家务劳动应该
be removed from the home. One of them was Marie Howland, a textile worker turned architect who was inspired by a cooperative community she spent a year at in Geese, France. It was known as the Social Palace. The Social Palace was built around an iron foundry, and the residents there took turns in a shared housekeeping program, which included a prepared food service for the 350 ironworkers and their families. And as Howland studied the design of the community, she began to dream up her own utopian society. Where a place like the social palace was the norm.
从家中移除的想法感兴趣。其中之一是玛丽·豪兰，她是一位从纺织工人转行的建筑师，受到她在法国吉斯生活过一年的合作社区的启发。它被称为“社会宫”。社会宫围绕一家铁铸造厂而建，那里的居民轮流参与共享家政计划，其中包括为350名钢铁工人和他们的家人提供预制食品服务。当豪兰研究该社区的设计时，她开始构思自己理想中的乌托邦社会。在那里，像社会宫这样的地方成为常态。
And she wrote a novel about it when she came back to the U.S. Marie Howland wasn't the only person using fiction to dream up an ideal future full of kitchenless houses. A lot of people were writing futuristic novels, including some books that depicted a feminist future with shared cooperative kitchens. The sense of possibility was palpable. And it wasn't only that women were writing them. I was surprised how much I found.
当她回到美国后，她为此写了一部小说。玛丽·豪兰并不是唯一一个利用虚构作品来构思充满无厨房房屋的理想未来的人。许多人都在写未来主义小说，包括一些描绘了拥有共享合作厨房的女性主义未来的书籍。那种可能性的感觉是显而易见的。而且不仅仅是女性在写这些。我惊讶地发现，
Men were writing these novels about women's liberation through new housing and new infrastructure. Some of them had everyone living in high-rise buildings. Another person cited everyone on a feminist planet Mars. Between popular fiction and a few real-world experiments, the concept of a kitchenless house was spreading. And in 1874, Marie Howland saw her chance to implement some of those ideas. She started working with two men, designers Albert Kimsey Owen and John Deerey. They were among the many people in the US at the time who believed that a more harmonious society was possible,
男性也在写这些关于通过新住房和新基础设施实现女性解放的小说。其中一些让每个人都住在高层建筑里。另一个人设想每个人都生活在一个女性主义的火星行星上。在通俗小说和一些现实世界的实验之间，无厨房房屋的概念正在传播。1874年，玛丽·豪兰看到了实施其中一些想法的机会。她开始与两位设计师阿尔伯特·金西·欧文和约翰·迪里合作。他们是当时美国众多相信更和谐社会是可能的人之一，
one where people lived collectively and jointly owned all means of production. And in the 1870s, together with Mary Howland, they set out to build a perfect town. They were promoting a new town in Mexico at the end of a railroad line. The town was called Topla Bumpo, and originally their designs just had single family homes with kitchens. But Marie Howland convinced them to sketch in small groups of kitchen freehouses, each with access to a shared kitchen, or residents would take turns working.
一个人们集体生活并共同拥有所有生产资料的社会。在19世纪70年代，他们与玛丽·豪兰一起着手建造一个完美的城镇。他们正在墨西哥铁路线的终点推广一个新城镇。这个城镇叫托波洛班波，最初他们的设计只是带有厨房的单户住宅。但玛丽·豪兰说服他们草拟了小群的无厨房房屋，每户都可以使用一个共享厨房，或者由居民轮流工作。
They had elaborate plans. They spent a lot of money drawing up these plans and publicizing the plan, so a lot of people heard about Topo Lobonpo. But not a lot of people got to live at Topo Lobonpo. The project ran out of money pretty quickly before Helen's kitchenless houses could even be built. To the male founders, those weren't a priority.
他们有详尽的计划。他们花了很多钱绘制这些计划并宣传该计划，所以很多人听说了托波洛班波。但并没有多少人真正住进了托波洛班波。该项目很快就耗尽了资金，甚至在豪兰的无厨房房屋建成之前就停工了。对于男性创始人来说，那些并不是优先事项。
But the dream wasn't over. In 1915, another feminist, an Alice Constance Austin, embarked on another kitchenless utopian experiment. Together with Job Heraman, a socialist politician, she set out to create a community called Yano Del Rio, outside LA. She thought it could be a city of kitchenless houses, and she thought that the food could come through some underground tunnels by trains. city of kitchenless houses. And she thought that the food could come through some underground tunnels by trains.
但梦想并没有结束。1915年，另一位女性主义者爱丽丝·康斯坦斯·奥斯汀开始了另一项无厨房的乌托邦实验。她与社会主义政治家乔布·赫拉曼一起，着手在洛杉矶郊外创建一个名为“里奥平原”的社区。她认为这可以成为一个无厨房房屋的城市，她认为食物可以通过一些地下隧道由火车运送。无厨房房屋的城市。她认为食物可以通过一些地下隧道由火车运送。
All right, food trains, now we're talking. Not railroad trains, but lines that would carry the food from a central kitchen to each house and would take away the dirty dishes. Austin drew maps upon maps and tons of floor plans. She published her ideas in the journal out of Yanodil Rio, the Western Comrade, and even applied to patent her underground food train idea. But like Top of the Bumbo, Yanodil Rio
好吧，食物火车，现在我们谈到点子上了。不是铁路火车，而是将食物从中央厨房运送到每家每户并带走脏碗碟的线路。奥斯汀绘制了地图又地图，还有大量的平面图。她在《里奥平原》杂志、《西方同志》上发表了她的想法，甚至申请了她的地下食物火车理念的专利。但就像托波洛班波一样，里奥平原
also struggled to get enough funding. The male founders weren't that into the idea of the kitchenless houses and the community fell apart before they could ever be constructed. But the kitchenless house movement still didn't die. Around the same era in England, the urban planner Ebenezer Howard actually incorporated Kitchenless homes into some of his garden city communities. He called these complexes cooperative quadrangles.
也难以获得足够的资金。男性创始人对无厨房房屋的想法并不感兴趣，社区在建成之前就解体了。但无厨房房屋运动并没有消亡。大约在同一时期，在英国，城市规划师埃比尼泽·霍华德实际上将无厨房住宅纳入了他的一些田园城市社区。他称这些综合体为“合作方庭”。
They had a shared courtyard and shared kitchen, surrounded by smaller kitchenless dwellings. He thought that they would be perfect for single women who were working courtyard and shared kitchen, surrounded by smaller kitchenless dwellings. He thought that they would be perfect for single women who are working, or for couples who didn't want to run on a elaborate domestic establishment, and his wife lived in one of them. But the late 19 teens in the U.S., the idea of ending the private kitchen was pretty mainstream. Big publications, including Ladies Home Journal, a magazine whose very title literally puts women in the home, ran articles promoting kitchenless houses.
它们有一个共享庭院和共享厨房，周围环绕着较小的无厨房住宅。他认为它们非常适合工作的单身女性，或者不想经营复杂家庭生活的夫妇，他的妻子就住在其中一个里。但到1910年代末的美国，结束私人厨房的想法已经相当主流了。包括《女士家庭杂志》在内的大型出版物，这本杂志的标题字面上就把女性放在了家里，刊登了推广无厨房房屋的文章。
They compared the private kitchen to the private spinning wheel, a relic of the past and a manifestation of oppressive unpaid labor that could be done much better on a larger scale. It was a popular and progressive movement, but it certainly wasn't without flaws. Many of these utopian movements were led by middle-class white women who didn't appear to seriously embrace the needs and contributions of black women and women of color. Many of these women had been violently forced into caretaking and housekeeping roles for generations through slavery and indentured servitude. And they were also fighting their own battles
他们将私人厨房比作私人纺纱机，那是过去的遗物，是压迫性无偿劳动的体现，而这种劳动本可以在更大规模上做得更好。这是一场流行且进步的运动，但它当然并非没有缺陷。许多这些乌托邦运动是由中产阶级白人女性领导的，她们似乎并没有认真拥抱黑人女性和有色人种女性的需求和贡献。许多这些女性几代人以来通过奴隶制和契约劳役被暴力地强迫从事照料和家政角色。她们也在为自己的尊严和报酬而战。
for dignity and pay. In time, the movement for kitchenless houses faced roadblocks it couldn't overcome. Inflation hit hard after World War I, and people were struggling. Figure out how to pay for prepared meals and service of women's liberation just wasn't a priority for everyone.
随着时间的推移，无厨房房屋运动面临着无法克服的障碍。一战后通货膨胀严重，人们生活艰难。弄清楚如何支付预制餐费，而女性解放的服务并不是每个人的优先事项。
Plus, more private kitchens meant more customers for electric companies who aggressively marketed their appliances to women. Instead of continuing the additional taxing, unpaid work of rallying for a shared drudgery-free future, many women settled for a dish-washing machine.
此外，更多的私人厨房意味着电力公司有更多的客户，他们积极向女性推销电器。许多女性没有继续那种额外的、繁重的、为共享无苦差事未来而奔走的无偿工作，而是满足于一台洗碗机。
The dream of mainstreaming the Kitchensless House was coming to an end, but the problem of the kitchen remained, and that brings us back to Margaretta Shuttolahatsky, the Austrian architect from the beginning of our story. In the 1920s, a young Shuttolahatsky took a very different approach to the home kitchen. She didn't want to eliminate it, she wanted to elevate it, with clever and scientifically informed design. She wanted kitchen work to move with the ease and quickness of a factory, so women could get in, end out, and on with their lives beyond the kitchen. Shuttla Hatskis' early work in public housing attracted the attention of city planners in Frankfurt, Germany.
主流化无厨房房屋的梦想即将终结，但厨房的问题依然存在，这让我们回到了我们故事开头提到的奥地利建筑师玛格丽特·舒特-利霍茨基。在20世纪20年代，年轻的舒特-利霍茨基对家庭厨房采取了截然不同的方法。她不想消除它，她想提升它，通过巧妙且科学的设计。她希望厨房工作能像工厂一样轻松快捷，这样女性就能进出厨房，继续她们厨房之外的生活。舒特-利霍茨基在公共住房方面的早期工作引起了德国法兰克福城市规划者的注意。
They were working on an ambitious government program to overhaul the way that residents of Frankfurt lived in the years after World War I. At the time, many Germans faced immense shortages of almost everything, including food, fuel, and crucially housing. In Frankfurt, people were living in old tenement buildings or sometimes just in garden plots. So the city government stepped in with an architectural agenda. It was called the New Frankfurt. For the architects of the New Frankfurt,
他们正在制定一项雄心勃勃的政府计划，以彻底改变一战后法兰克福居民的生活方式。当时，许多德国人面临着几乎所有东西的巨大短缺，包括食物、燃料，以及至关重要的住房。在法兰克福，人们住在旧公寓楼里，或者有时只是住在花园地块里。因此，市政府介入并制定了一项建筑议程。它被称为“新法兰克福”。对于新法兰克福的建筑师来说，
the question really becomes how can we create good housing for a large amount of people in a short amount of time? As E. Isnerer is an assistant professor at Princeton. She's currently working on a biography of Margaret the Shuttah-Lahatsky. And she says, to answer that question, the architects of the new Frankfurt took a novel approach. They looked to mass production. The idea becomes how can we use prefabricated elements
问题真正变成了：我们如何在短时间内为大量人口创造良好的住房？E. 伊斯纳是普林斯顿大学的助理教授。她目前正在撰写玛格丽特·舒特-利霍茨基的传记。她说，为了回答这个问题，新法兰克福的建筑师们采取了一种新颖的方法。他们着眼于大规模生产。理念变成了：我们如何利用预制构件
like walls, but in some cases also entire room units to produce housing stock quickly. For the first time ever, the German government encouraged the shells of buildings and sometimes entire rooms, fixtures and all to be assembled in a factory by machines and then set down on the construction site by crane. These new mass-produced apartments
比如墙壁，但在某些情况下甚至是整个房间单元，来快速生产住房存量。德国政府首次鼓励建筑外壳，有时甚至是整个房间、固定装置等，由机器在工厂组装，然后由起重机放置在施工现场。这些新的大规模生产的公寓
needed cheap and compact kitchens, and for that, the director of the new Frankfurt project tapped Shutelohatsky, and she began by studying kitchens on trains and ships. They were obviously wonderful models for efficiency because they didn't have much space, and space was expensive. That's Mary McLeod again. And she says that Chutolihatsky came up with all of these thoughtful, practical,
需要廉价且紧凑的厨房，为此，新法兰克福项目的负责人启用了舒特-利霍茨基，她开始研究火车和船上的厨房。它们显然是效率的绝佳模型，因为它们没有太多空间，而空间很昂贵。这是玛丽·麦克劳德。她说，舒特-利霍茨基为她的厨房设计想出了所有这些体贴、实用
and super space-saving touches for her kitchen design. Designs I got to see firsthand when I visited that kitchen in the museum. Like a Murphy bed style, fold down ironing board. Or this thing called the cook box, which is kind of like today's crock pod, except it just used residual heat from the stove to slow cook meats or grains or whatever else.
且超级节省空间的点子。当我参观博物馆里的那个厨房时，我亲眼看到了这些设计。比如墨菲床式的折叠熨衣板。或者这个叫“烹饪盒”的东西，它有点像今天的慢炖锅，只是它利用炉灶的余热来慢炖肉类、谷物或其他任何东西。
And one of my favorite features, these 12 identical measuring cups with spouts that fit into cubby holes on the wall, each labeled with the name of a different grain or food stuff. Those let you measure and pour without dirtying up multiple cups and dishes. It were complaints that she didn't have a big enough container for potatoes, but for the most part it was seen as amazingly efficient.
我最喜欢的功能之一是这12个带有壶嘴的相同量杯，它们可以放入墙上的小隔间里，每个都贴有不同谷物或食品的名称。这些让你无需弄脏多个杯子和盘子就能测量和倾倒。有人抱怨她没有足够大的土豆容器，但总的来说，它被认为是非常高效的。
And that efficiency was, of course, by design. Chutla Hatsuki was inspired by scientific management, a popular idea in the states back in the 1920s. It was mostly applied to factories, where managers would obsessively streamline workflows in order to theoretically maximize their profits. Chute Le Hotsky applied those ideas to the kitchen, and in the interest of minimizing work for so-called housewives,
当然，这种效率是设计出来的。舒特-利霍茨基受到科学管理的启发，这是20世纪20年代在美国流行的一种理念。它主要应用于工厂，经理们会强迫性地精简工作流程，以理论上最大化利润。舒特-利霍茨基将这些想法应用于厨房，为了尽量减少所谓家庭主妇的工作，
she did test to eradicate any excess movements. Shuddehotsky designed so-called motion studies for the design of the Frankfurt kitchen, where she mapped intensely what are the shortest paths between different kitchen elements that you would use in a regular cooking session, let's say. She tracked women's movements like football plays or complex dance steps with little lines across the floor and then streamlined accordingly. In her kitchen, no single step or reach of the arm was unnecessary. Women would be like basketball players holding the ball.
她测试了如何根除任何多余的动作。舒特-利霍茨基为法兰克福厨房的设计进行了所谓的动作研究，她深入绘制了在常规烹饪过程中，不同厨房元素之间最短的路径。她像足球战术或复杂的舞步一样追踪女性的动作，在地板上画出小线条，然后相应地进行精简。在她的厨房里，没有一个步骤或手臂的伸展是多余的。女性会像拿着球的篮球运动员一样。
Never more than a pivot or step away from where they needed to go. She really just wanted to make women's life easier, so they had time for more creative, pleasurable activities, and even intellectual pursuits. That was the real goal of it. The Frankfurt kitchen was mass-produced in batches of 10 to 15, with little variations or changes made throughout. Between 1926 and 1930, the pre-fab kitchen was installed in about 10,000 public housing units in Frankfurt, and architects and public housing leaders across Europe quickly sang
距离她们需要去的地方永远不会超过一个转身或一步的距离。她真的只是想让女性的生活更轻松，这样她们就有时间进行更有创造力、更愉快的活动，甚至是智力追求。这才是真正的目标。法兰克福厨房以10到15个为一批进行大规模生产，其间会有一些小的变化或调整。1926年至1930年间，这种预制厨房被安装在法兰克福约10,000套公共住房中，欧洲各地的建筑师和公共住房领导人很快就对其赞不绝口。
its praises. But in practice, this renowned kitchen didn't always jive with how people, women, actually wanted to use their kitchen. Sure, there were those complaints that the bin for potatoes was too small, but there were bigger issues. For a long time, kitchens had been integrated into large living rooms, where people would cook around a big open hearth. But in the compact new Frankford housing,
但在实践中，这个著名的厨房并不总是与人们（女性）实际想要使用厨房的方式相契合。当然，有人抱怨土豆箱太小，但还有更大的问题。长期以来，厨房一直被整合到大型客厅中，人们会在一个大的开放式壁炉周围做饭。但在紧凑的新法兰克福住房中，
the kitchen was now separate from other living spaces. First, there's work, and that's the kitchen. And second, there's living relaxation, pleasure, free time, and that's the living room. That sounds pretty good in theory. Leave the drudgery behind you when you close the kitchen door. But for many women, household labor was so gendered that they also had kids to take care of. Those joint living room kitchens of old with the big open hearths and the slap together furniture, they may have been slip-shod, but you could have company or watch the kids even while you cooked. But now, the kitchen was way too small
厨房现在与其他生活空间分开了。首先是工作，那就是厨房。其次是生活、放松、快乐、空闲时间，那就是客厅。理论上听起来不错。当你关上厨房门时，就把苦差事抛在脑后。但对许多女性来说，家务劳动是如此性别化，以至于她们还要照顾孩子。那些旧的联合客厅厨房，有着大的开放式壁炉和拼凑的家具，它们可能很简陋，但你可以在做饭时有伴或照看孩子。但现在，厨房太小了，
to watch a child in. There are reports of people trying to cram their dining sets into the small 60 square foot Frankfurt kitchen because these were the habits and customs they were used and they wanted to continue life as it suited them. Then there was the fact that all those glorious handy-do dads proved to be a bit of a trap. The fold-down ironing board, the 12 identical, easy to access, aluminum measuring cups, the modern stove and oven,
无法照看孩子。有报道称，人们试图把他们的餐具塞进60平方英尺的小法兰克福厨房里，因为这些是他们习惯的习惯和习俗，他们想继续过适合自己的生活。然后是这样一个事实：所有那些光荣的方便小玩意儿被证明有点像个陷阱。折叠熨衣板，12个相同的、易于拿取的铝制量杯，现代炉灶和烤箱，
they may have been placed efficiently, but that efficiency made it possible to do so much more. Sure, it may take only four seconds to fold your ironing board down from your wall, but now you have this omnipresent ironing board in the kitchen. And now you're expected to press your napkins. Who does that? This society expectations on what constituted labor well done within the domestic were just greatest, so you would have to launder more often, or you would have to cook more elaborate meals,
它们可能放置得很高效，但那种效率使得做更多事情成为可能。当然，把熨衣板从墙上放下来可能只需要四秒钟，但现在你的厨房里有一个无处不在的熨衣板。现在你被期望熨烫餐巾纸。谁会那样做？社会对家庭内部劳动质量的期望太高了，所以你必须更频繁地洗衣服，或者你必须做更复杂的饭菜，
and more technologies usually will not mean less work, but a higher expectation on the laborer. On top of all that, many of these new kitchens relied on electric appliances, and electricity was still really expensive. It was pretty new. When residents couldn't pay the electric bill, that meant they couldn't cook. Some residents wrote to their local housing office through tenants groups.
更多的技术通常并不意味着更少的工作，而是对劳动者更高的期望。最重要的是，许多这些新厨房依赖电器，而电力仍然非常昂贵。它相当新。当居民付不起电费时，意味着他们无法做饭。一些居民通过租户团体写信给当地住房办公室。
Others took their complaints directly to the press, but the city wasn't interested in going back to the old ways. When they voiced their concerns, the response by the municipality was not to tweak the designs, but to actually implement, quote unquote, education programs. They held classes on how to use the Frankfurt kitchen and his new technologies.
其他人直接向媒体投诉，但市政府对回到旧方式不感兴趣。当他们表达担忧时，市政当局的回应不是调整设计，而是实施所谓的“教育计划”。他们举办了关于如何使用法兰克福厨房及其新技术的课程。
They made a silent film as a sort of PR campaign. The complaints about the cordoned off kitchen didn't die down, but the leaders of this architectural revolution were adamant that so-called modernism was the way of the future. They kept building Frankfurt kitchens, and other architects kept taking notes. But as the Nazi Party gained power throughout the late 1920s, they cut a lot of the public housing initiatives. Manufacture of the actual Frankfurt kitchen ended in 1930. Even so, the design remained hugely influential in a lot of places.
他们制作了一部默片作为一种公关活动。关于被隔离厨房的抱怨并没有平息，但这场建筑革命的领导者们坚持认为所谓的现代主义是未来的方向。他们继续建造法兰克福厨房，其他建筑师也继续做笔记。但随着纳粹党在20世纪20年代末掌权，他们削减了许多公共住房计划。法兰克福厨房的实际制造于1930年结束。即便如此，该设计在许多地方仍然极具影响力。
In the US, everyone from private companies to government agencies were coming up with kitchen designs that looked a lot like Shota Lahatsky's. These plans were developed for people just like you. Like when the Department of Agriculture launched the step Stepsaving Kitchen in the late 1940s. Since you folks have an old fashioned kitchen, you know the amount of stooping and reaching that must be done and the running from one corner of the kitchen to the other. That's why we've developed this kitchen. Even though imitators were everywhere, Shytla Hotsky didn't always get credit
在美国，从私营公司到政府机构，每个人都在想出看起来很像舒特-利霍茨基设计的厨房设计。这些计划是为像你这样的人开发的。比如当农业部在20世纪40年代末推出“省力厨房”时。既然你们这些家伙有老式厨房，你们就知道必须做多少弯腰和伸展动作，以及从厨房的一个角落跑到另一个角落。这就是为什么我们开发了这个厨房。尽管模仿者无处不在，但舒特-利霍茨基并不总是得到认可
as the mother of the modern kitchen in the decades after she designed it. But then as the 50s gave way to the 60s and 70s, Shytla Hotsky and her Frankfurt kitchen started to get renewed attention from architects and historians. She was rediscovered in the context of second wave feminism as kind of a main figure that should be canonized.
作为现代厨房之母，在她设计它后的几十年里。但随着50年代让位于60年代和70年代，舒特-利霍茨基和她的法兰克福厨房开始受到建筑师和历史学家的重新关注。她在第二波女性主义的背景下被重新发现，作为一种应该被奉为经典的中心人物。
In 1980, the city of Vienna gave her a big architecture award. But Chutelahatsky's resurgent popularity opened her ideas up to criticism from some other second wave feminists who took a harder line against women's unpaid labor. Some architects and academics pointed out that Chutolahatsky's kitchen may have been streamlined, but it's still accepted that women would have to do a lot of cooking and
1980年，维也纳市授予她一项大型建筑奖。但舒特-利霍茨基重新兴起的知名度使她的想法受到了一些其他第二波女性主义者的批评，她们对女性的无偿劳动采取了更强硬的立场。一些建筑师和学者指出，舒特-利霍茨基的厨房可能已经精简了，但它仍然接受女性必须做大量烹饪和
cleaning without pay. And activists, including members of a new international movement called Wages for Housework, picked up the unfinished business of the 19th and 20th Century feminists. They argued that the entire capitalist system would collapse if there was a widespread demand for pay. One vocal leader of the movement even called for a return to the shared kitchen efforts of the 19th century. So was Marguerite Sztutolacksky's design really so radical? She absolutely wanted to lessen the burden of housework for women. But the legacy of the Frankfurt kitchen is pretty murky.
清洁工作而没有报酬的事实。包括一个名为“家务劳动工资”的新国际运动成员在内的活动家们，捡起了19世纪和20世纪女性主义者未竟的事业。他们认为，如果对报酬有广泛的需求，整个资本主义体系就会崩溃。该运动的一位直言不讳的领导人甚至呼吁回归19世纪的共享厨房努力。那么玛格丽特·舒特-利霍茨基的设计真的那么激进吗？她绝对想减轻女性的家务负担。但法兰克福厨房的遗产相当模糊。
And toward the end of her life, even Schüttel-Hatski herself came to turn her back on this kitchen, she designed before she even turned 30. So the famous quote is, so when I was in the first born, that all of you would always talk about this Dachte Küchenie. If I would have known that this is everything that anyone would ever talk about, I would have never designed this damned kitchen. That seems like the end, right?
而在她生命的尽头，甚至舒特-利霍茨基自己也开始背弃这个她在不到30岁时就设计的厨房。所以那句名言是，当我是第一个出生的人时，你们所有人都会一直谈论这个Dachte Küchenie。如果我知道这就是所有人都会谈论的一切，我永远不会设计这个该死的厨房。这看起来像是结局，对吧？
But there's one more thing. Another side to this whole story, because you can intellectualize the design of a kitchen until the watched pot boils. But the thing is, a lot of us, regardless of gender, we love our kitchens. There's a magnetism to kitchens, like every party ever somehow finds all attendees crammed into the kitchen. Kitchens are hallowed grounds, because kitchens are where food is. Food and cooking were not invented as mechanisms for women to be oppressed, right?
但还有一件事。整个故事的另一面，因为你可以把厨房的设计理性化，直到烧开的水壶沸腾。但问题是，我们很多人，无论性别，我们都爱我们的厨房。厨房有一种磁力，就像每次聚会不知何故都会发现所有参加者都挤在厨房里一样。厨房是神圣的土地，因为厨房里有食物。食物和烹饪并不是作为女性被压迫的机制而发明的，对吧？
Like food is for us to eat and be nourished by. The way it became a tool of oppression is because of men. Kayla Stewart is a food and travel journalist who writes primarily about African-American food ways. And she says, the kitchen is not to blame for a centuries-old system that doesn't value women's work. Kayla really likes to cook. She writes about food for a living.
就像食物是为了让我们吃并获得营养一样。它成为压迫工具的方式是因为男性。凯拉·斯图尔特是一位主要撰写非裔美国人饮食方式的食品和旅游记者。她说，厨房不应为几个世纪以来不重视女性劳动的体系负责。凯拉真的很喜欢做饭。她以写食物为生。
I also love to cook, and I worked in commercial kitchens for years. And we both think that the idea of simply streamlining kitchens, or especially eradicating them, it has some holes. Yeah, I think it misses a lot of things. Kayla says many women across the world, across arrows and generations, have had a special knowledge of food. Much of what we are eating today, we have thanks to women and many women, unfortunately,
我也喜欢做饭，我曾在商业厨房工作多年。我们俩都认为，仅仅精简厨房，或者特别是根除它们，有一些漏洞。是的，我认为它遗漏了很多东西。凯拉说，世界各地、各个时代和几代人的许多女性都拥有关于食物的特殊知识。我们今天吃的很多东西，都要感谢女性，不幸的是，许多女性，
whose names we might never know. A lot of the knowledge that women have about food is rooted in oppression. But Tikaela, not celebrating and valuing that knowledge, just adds insult to injury. Because the home kitchen can also be a classroom, a place to connect with loved ones and family and culture. To her, the issue is more about whether or not women have a choice to be
我们可能永远不知道她们的名字。女性拥有的许多关于食物的知识都植根于压迫。但对凯拉来说，不庆祝和重视这些知识只会雪上加霜。因为家庭厨房也可以是一个教室，一个与亲人、家庭和文化联系的地方。对她来说，问题更多在于女性是否有选择权
in the kitchen. I'm less concerned about whether or not a woman should be in the kitchen and more concerned about our women able to transform the cooking that they've done and the ways in which they've nourished societies for centuries into a career if they want to, if they show shoes, if women do not want to be in the kitchen, do they have other options? To me, those are the things that we should be focusing on when we're talking about them and is them in the kitchen. Yes, design matters, but a few less trips across the kitchen is not what's going to fix the great discrepancies and care work.
在厨房里。我不太关心女性是否应该在厨房里，而更关心我们的女性是否能够将她们几个世纪以来所做的烹饪以及她们滋养社会的方式转化为职业，如果她们愿意的话，如果她们选择的话。如果女性不想在厨房里，她们还有其他选择吗？对我来说，当我们谈论她们和厨房里的她们时，这些才是我们应该关注的事情。是的，设计很重要，但少走几趟厨房并不能解决护理工作的巨大差异。
That takes a whole system, a system that not only respects and values the contributions of home cooks, but also offers affordable food options if we don't want to cook, and things like school meals and jobs that leave us with energy so that cooking can be fun. If those things were in place, any number of kitchen layouts could be empowering, from Shuzula Hatsuki's lightning fast, bite-sized design to Alice Constance Austin's utopian collective kitchens. Because I love to cook.
这需要一个完整的体系，一个不仅尊重和重视家庭厨师贡献的体系，而且还提供负担得起的食物选择（如果我们不想做饭的话），以及学校餐和让我们有精力工作，这样烹饪才能变得有趣。如果这些东西到位了，任何数量的厨房布局都可以赋予力量，从舒特-利霍茨基闪电般快速、一口大小的设计到爱丽丝·康斯坦斯·奥斯汀的乌托邦集体厨房。因为我喜欢做饭。
But some evenings, I would gladly receive my prepared dinner on a miniature train, especially if it takes my dishes away too. Coming up after the break, the incredible story of Shuttla Hotsky's life after the Frankfurt kitchen. We are back with reporter Katie Thornton, and we want to talk a little bit more about who Shuttla Hotsky was as a person, because she was pretty amazing. Yeah, she really was pretty amazing.
但有些晚上，我很乐意在微型火车上收到我的预制晚餐，特别是如果它也带走我的脏碗碟的话。休息后回来，舒特-利霍茨基在法兰克福厨房之后的生活的不可思议的故事。我们回到了记者凯蒂·桑顿身边，我们想多谈谈舒特-利霍茨基作为一个人的身份，因为她非常了不起。是的，她确实非常了不起。
Yeah, she really was. And specifically, I wanted to talk a bit about her political trajectory after the Frankfurt kitchen, because she really is a remarkable person. And I think her life helps shed some light onto the sort of complexity of her legacy. Cool. So, we mentioned that in the story, in the 1930s,
是的，她确实是。具体来说，我想谈谈她在法兰克福厨房之后的政治轨迹，因为她确实是一个非凡的人。我认为她的生活有助于阐明她遗产的复杂性。酷。所以，我们在故事中提到，在20世纪30年代，
and as the Nazis rose to power in interwar Germany, they did away with a lot of the social housing projects and efforts that were going on. And Ernst Mai, who was directing the new Frankfurt project, handed up gathering 16 architects, including Shutelohatsky and fleeing to the Soviet Union in 1930. And Shutelohatsky ended up working there. She and her husband Wilhelm Shuta helped design collective kitchens and nurseries
随着纳粹在战间期德国掌权，他们废除了许多正在进行的社会住房项目和努力。而指导新法兰克福项目的恩斯特·迈，最终召集了16位建筑师，包括舒特-利霍茨基，并于1930年逃往苏联。舒特-利霍茨基最终在那里工作。她和她的丈夫威廉·舒特帮助设计了集体厨房和托儿所
in the Soviet Union. They left there in 1937 and in 1938, they moved to Istanbul, where another architect had secured them jobs. So I guess she would have been in Turkey as what ends up becoming World War II was really escalating. Yeah, exactly. And in Turkey, she actually joins the clandestine Communist Party
在苏联。他们于1937年离开那里，并于1938年搬到伊斯坦布尔，另一位建筑师在那里为他们争取到了工作。所以我猜她会在土耳其，当时第二次世界大战真的在升级。是的，完全正确。在土耳其，她实际上加入了秘密共产党
and an anti-fascist resistance cell. So she's fighting Nazis. She is. Yeah, she goes to fight the Nazis. And as part of her resistance work in 1940, she's sent on a mission to Vienna, where she's tasked with gathering anti-fascist literature. So it can be reproduced and distributed back in Turkey. She also does things like deliver messages to members of the communist resistance throughout Austria, and she communicates with the leader of the resistance there, warning him to leave the country when it becomes clear that he may be in danger.
和一个反法西斯抵抗小组。所以她在与纳粹作战。她是。是的，她去与纳粹作战。作为她1940年抵抗工作的一部分，她被派往维也纳执行任务，她的任务是收集反法西斯文学作品。这样它就可以在土耳其被复制和分发。她还做了一些事情，比如向奥地利各地的共产主义抵抗成员传递信息，并与那里的抵抗运动领导人沟通，警告他在情况变得明显他可能处于危险中时离开该国。
Wow, I mean, this is really risky, spy stuff. It's super risky. And in fact, you know, when she's on this mission on the day before she's set to return home to Turkey, she's actually captured by the Gestapo and imprisoned. Oh, my. And she's moved between various prisons and labor camps in Austria and Germany. And ultimately, she's imprisoned for four years.
哇，我的意思是，这真的是高风险的间谍活动。这超级危险。事实上，你知道，当她在任务中，在她准备回到土耳其的前一天，她实际上被盖世太保抓获并监禁了。哦，天哪。她在奥地利和德国的各个监狱和劳改营之间被转移。最终，她被监禁了四年。
She's forced into solitary confinement for a lot of that time, and she's also brought to the Gestapo's headquarters to be interrogated, and that is just an absolutely horrific place. An estimated 50,000 people were murdered at that location alone. Shutolohatsky's male comrade, who she was captured with, he was one of the people who was executed. But she eventually made it out. Yeah, she does. In April of 1945, Shutelahatsky's finally freed by American soldiers. But this is where her life takes another turn.
在那段时间里，她大部分时间都被迫单独监禁，她还被带到盖世太保的总部接受审讯，那绝对是一个极其恐怖的地方。据估计，仅在该地点就有50,000人被谋杀。与她一起被捕的舒特-利霍茨基的男性同志，他是被处决的人之一。但她最终逃了出来。是的，她做到了。1945年4月，舒特-利霍茨基终于被美国士兵释放。但这就是她生活发生另一个转折的地方。
A couple years after she's freed, she returns to Austria, her home. And Austria had been part of Nazi Germany until 1945. And when Shutelahatsky returned to Austria as a former political prisoner of the Nazi regime, she was not warmly received. Here's S.C. Isterer, who we heard from in the main story. She had left Austria when she was in her late 20s as a fairly successful young architect who had done completed very large commissions had published work at a very young age.
在她获释几年后，她回到了自己的家乡奥地利。直到1945年，奥地利一直是纳粹德国的一部分。当舒特里哈茨基作为纳粹政权的前政治犯回到奥地利时，她并没有受到热烈欢迎。这是我们在主故事中听到的S.C. 艾斯特勒（S.C. Eisterer）的声音。她离开奥地利时已近30岁，是一位相当成功的年轻建筑师，在很年轻的时候就完成了非常大的委托项目并发表过作品。
She returned to Austria in her late 40s starting 50s as somebody who would soon come to realize that she had lost her career as an architect in Austria over her resistance activity. There was still deep anti-Semitism among many Austrian citizens and leaders. The resistance movement in Austria was always very marginal during the war, as he says. After the war, the Austrian government tried to ignore the nation's history as perpetrators of Nazi violence.
她回到奥地利时已近50岁，很快意识到自己因为抵抗活动而在奥地利失去了建筑师的职业生涯。当时许多奥地利公民和领导人中仍然存在深刻的反犹太主义。正如他所说，奥地利的抵抗运动在战争期间一直处于边缘地位。战后，奥地利政府试图忽视该国作为纳粹暴力肇事者的历史。
Against the backdrop of the Cold War, anti-communist sentiment grew in the 1950s, and having worked with the communist resistance, Shutolihatsky maintained her allegiance to the Communist Party of Austria for the rest of her life. So when Shutolihatsky comes back after working with the resistance,
在冷战的背景下，反共情绪在20世纪50年代高涨，而由于曾与共产主义抵抗组织合作，舒特里哈茨基余生都保持着对奥地利共产党的忠诚。所以当舒特里哈茨基在与抵抗组织合作后回来时，
she only got two contracts from the city of Vienna, despite her architectural expertise and her knowledge of kitchens and childcare and everything. Wow, so she was really shut down after this. Yes, she really was. I mean, for decades, she worked almost exclusively on private homes, or she would take on big public projects in China
尽管她拥有建筑专业知识，并且精通厨房、育儿设施等各方面，但她只从维也纳市获得了两个合同。哇，所以她在那之后真的被排挤了。是的，确实如此。我的意思是，几十年来，她几乎只从事私人住宅的设计，或者在中国、
or Cuba or the Soviet Union. And all the while, she's getting sort of more and more involved in both the Communist Party of Austria and also the women's movement. So I guess in the while, she's getting more and more involved in both the Communist Party of Austria and also the Women's Movement. So I guess in the story, when we said that she didn't always get the credit she deserved as the mother of the modern kitchen, like, this is why. Yeah, I think that's right. She was really shut out.
古巴或苏联承接大型公共项目。与此同时，她越来越多地参与到奥地利共产党和妇女运动中。所以我猜在故事中，当我们说她作为“现代厨房之母”没有得到应有的认可时，原因就在这里。是的，我想是对的。她确实被排挤在外了。
Yeah. But I know in the 70s and 80s, she was kind of put back in the spotlight. I mean, so how did that happen? Yeah, you know, in the piece, we talked a lot about how the growth of second wave feminism meant that her work sort of got a second look. And in 1980, she got a big award for her architectural work from the city of Vienna. So slowly, you know, the government was beginning
是的。但我知道在70和80年代，她又重新回到了聚光灯下。我的意思是，那是怎么发生的？是的，你知道，在文章中，我们谈了很多关于第二波女权主义的兴起如何让她的作品得到了重新审视。1980年，她因其建筑作品获得了维也纳市颁发的一项大奖。所以慢慢地，你知道，政府开始
to embrace her again, but, you know, it was really complicated. In 1988, for example, she was selected to get this incredibly high honor for arts and sciences in Austria, but she rejected it because it would have been awarded by Kurt Walteim, who was the president of Austria at the time, and had been an intelligence officer with the Nazi army. And he was banned from entering the US due to his involvement with war crimes. So she was a very political figure until she died just before her 103rd birthday in 2000. Well, what a fascinating human being.
重新接纳她，但你知道，这真的很复杂。例如，1988年，她被选中获得奥地利艺术与科学领域的极高荣誉，但她拒绝了，因为该奖项将由时任奥地利总统库尔特·瓦尔德海姆（Kurt Waldheim）颁发，而他曾是纳粹军队的情报官员。由于参与战争罪行，他被禁止进入美国。所以她一直是一位非常有政治色彩的人物，直到2000年她在103岁生日前夕去世。嗯，真是一位迷人的人。
I'm so glad I know a little bit more about her after the Frankfurt kitchen. Yeah, she really is incredible. Well, thank you so much for talking with us, Katie. It's pleasure as always. Thanks, Roman. 99% invisible was produced this week by Katie Thornton. It was edited by Delaney Hall, original music by Swan Rihau,
我很高兴在了解法兰克福厨房之后，对她有了更多的认识。是的，她真的很了不起。好吧，非常感谢你和我们交谈，凯蒂。一如既往，这是我的荣幸。谢谢，罗曼。《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）本周由凯蒂·桑顿（Katie Thornton）制作。由德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）编辑，原创音乐由斯旺·里豪（Swan Rihau）创作，
sound mix by Hazik Bin Amad Farid. Kirk Olset is our digital director, the rest of the team, includes Chris Barube, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martín Gonzales, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Loshamadon, Jacob Moltenadoález, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashima Don, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below-go was created by Stefan Lawrence. SE Eistler's forthcoming book is called Memories of the Resistance, Margaret T. Schutelohatsky
混音由哈齐克·本·阿马德·法里德（Hazik Bin Amad Farid）完成。柯克·奥尔塞特（Kirk Olset）是我们的数字总监，团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·迪利恩（Jason Dillion）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín Gonzales）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、拉希玛·唐（Lashima Don）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。S.C. 艾斯特勒即将出版的书名为《抵抗的记忆：玛格丽特·T·舒特里哈茨基
and the Architecture of Collective Disnance, 1919-1989. That'll be out in the next 18 months from Louven University Press. Special thanks this week to historian Martina Hessler for her scholarship on resistance to the Frankfurt kitchen and huge congrats to Katie Thornton, who by the way just won a Peabody award for her series on right-wing radio. It's called the divided dial we featured part of her reporting, but you should check out the whole series on the on the media feed if you haven't heard already. It's fantastic and award winning.
与集体居住的建筑，1919-1989》。该书将在未来18个月内由鲁汶大学出版社（Leuven University Press）出版。本周特别感谢历史学家玛蒂娜·赫斯勒（Martina Hessler）对法兰克福厨房抵抗运动的研究，并向凯蒂·桑顿表示热烈祝贺，顺便提一下，她刚刚凭借关于右翼广播的系列节目获得了皮博迪奖。该节目名为《分裂的表盘》（The Divided Dial），我们曾节选了她的部分报道，但如果你还没听过，你应该去“On the Media”频道查看整个系列。它非常精彩且屡获殊荣。
We are a part of the Citrus and Sirius XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99 PI org. Run Instagram, Reddit and ticked on to you can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Run Instagram, Reddit, and tick dot two. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，坐落在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。你也可以在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上关注我们。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目链接以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。目前该集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。